List of things that make men instantly more hot
starting off with No. 1 when they're unaware of how attractive they are
when men are oblivious to how attractive they are
it's just an instant pantry dropper
men who are aware of this are kind of the worst
No. two when a man has five o'clock shadow
okay this is a personal preference
but it gets me every time
No. three when he has a low voice
not like a Barry White boy
but a nice low voice
can make someone's less attractive qualities way more attractive
I’ve developed a crush on a voice alone
No. 4 the ability to have banter
there's nothing worse than trying to have witty banter with a brick wall
that actually makes guys less attractive
No. five smelling like a man
and not necessarily anything that's sold out of a bottle
just light pheromones
that scent is so darn appealing to any woman
No. six when he only has eyes for you
if you're going out on a date with him and he's looking all around
that's not attractive
But when he only has eyes for you that is so attractive
and if you do this you'll probably get lucky
No. 7 when he says your name unexpectedly
there's just something so powerful about when a man says your name
No. 8 when he can at least cook one meal well
He doesn't have to be Gordon Ramsay
but there's nothing better than waking up the next morning
and he's prepared you eggs, bacon pancakes
that's hot
No. 9 loving your pets
there's nothing cuter than when a man likes your pet
is just so adorable
No. 10 not answering texts when he's with you
at least for the first couple days
Full attention means respect